J'aimerais vous parler aujourd'hui des deux plus importantes tendances sociales du siècle à venir,
et peut-être des 10.000 prochaines années.
Mais je voudrais commencer par une étude que j'ai réalisée sur le sentiment amoureux
parce que c'est mon travail le plus récent.
Mes collègues et moi-même avons réuni 32 personnes, éperdument amoureuses
et leur avons fait passer un scanner IRM du cerveau.
17 étaient fous amoureux et leur amour leur était rendu.
15 autres étaient également éperdument amoureux mais venaient de se faire plaquer.
C'est ce dont je voudrais d'abord vous parler
avant d'évoquer mon idée du futur du sentiment amoureux.
"Qu'est-ce qu'aimer?" a dit Shakespeare.
Je pense que nos ancêtres... je pense que les êtres humains se posent cette question
depuis le jour où ils se sont assis près d'un feu ou qu'ils ont contemplé les étoiles, il y a un million d'années.
J'ai commencé par essayer de comprendre ce qu'est le sentiment amoureux
en étudiant les 45 dernières années de recherche sur ... uniquement la psychologie
et ce qui en ressort, c'est qu'un groupe d'événements spécifiques se réalise lorsqu'on tombe amoureux.
La première chose est ce que j'appelle...
une personne commence à prendre "une dimension particulière".
Un jour, un chauffeur-routier m'a dit:
"Le monde avait un nouveau centre et ce centre s'appelait Mary Anne."
George Bernard Shaw l'a dit un peu différemment.
Il a dit, "l'Amour c'est surestimer les différences entre une femme et une autre."
Et c'est exactement ce que nous faisons. (Rires)
Et votre attention ne se porte plus que sur cette seule personne.
Vous pouvez faire la liste de ce qui ne vous plaît pas chez elle
mais vous mettez tout cela de côté et vous vous concentrez sur ce que vous aimez chez elle.
Chaucer a dit "L'amour est aveugle."
Pour comprendre le sentiment amoureux,
j'ai décidé de lire des poèmes du monde entier
et je voudrais vous lire un très court poème chinois du huitième siècle
car c'est un exemple quasi-parfait d'un homme totalement envoûté par une femme.
C'est un petit peu comme lorsque vous êtes follement amoureux de quelqu'un
et que vous marchez dans un parking.
Sa voiture est différente de toutes les autres.
Son verre de vin dans un dîner est différent de tous les autres.
Et là, un homme est devenu accro à un matelas en bambou.
Voici le poème. C'est d'un homme qui s'appelle Yuan Chen :
"Je ne peux supporter de ranger le matelas de bambou.
La nuit où je t'ai ramenée chez moi, je t'ai regardée le dérouler."
Il est devenu accro à un matelas en bambou
probablement en raison de la forte sécrétion de dopamine de son cerveau
comme c'est le cas pour vous et moi.
Donc, non seulement cette personne prend une dimension particulière
mais en plus votre attention se fixe sur elle.
Vous l'idéalisez. Mais vous ressentez une énergie très forte.
Un Polynésien a dit : "C'était comme sauter dans le ciel."
Vous veillez toute la nuit. Vous marchez jusqu'à l'aube.
Lorsque les choses vont bien, vous ressentez une exaltation intense
et un profond désespoir lorsqu'elles vont mal.
Une vraie dépendance à cette personne.
Un homme d'affaires new-yorkais m'a dit un jour: "Tout ce qu'elle aimait, j'aimais."
C'est simple. L'amour est très simple.
Vous devenez très possessif sexuellement.
Vous savez, si vous couchez avec une personne de passage
vous vous moquez de savoir si elle couche avec d'autres.
Mais dès l'instant où vous tombez amoureux,
vous devenez très possessif sexuellement.
Je crois que c'est darwinien... il y a un enjeu darwinien dans cet aspect des choses.
L'enjeu est de créer un lien suffisamment fort entre deux personnes
pour élever des enfants ensemble.
Mais le principal trait de l'amour est le besoin :
un besoin intense d'être avec cette personne, pas seulement sexuellement mais émotionnellement.
Ou plutôt... ce serait agréable de partager le même lit
mais vous voulez aussi qu'elle vous appelle au téléphone, qu'elle vous invite à sortir, etc.,
Qu'elle vous dise qu'elle vous aime.
L'autre caractéristique principale est la motivation.
Le moteur de votre cerveau se met en marche et vous désirez cette personne.
Puis cela devient une obsession.
Quand je mets ces personnes dans la machine, juste avant que je ne les mette dans le scanner,
je leur pose toutes sortes de questions.
Mais ma question la plus importante est toujours la même.
C'est : "Quel pourcentage du jour et de la nuit passez vous à penser à cette personne?"
Et effectivement, ils répondent "Toute la journée, toute la nuit, je ne peux jamais arrêter de penser à elle ou à lui."
Et ensuite, la toute dernière question que je leur pose...
J'ai toujours besoin de faire un effort pour poser cette question
parce que je ne suis pas un psychologue,
je ne travaille jamais avec des personnes qui sont dans une situation traumatique.
Ma question finale est toujours la même.
Je demande : "Pourriez-vous mourir pour lui ou elle?"
Et, effectivement, ces personnes répondent "Oui!"
un peu comme si je leur avais demandé de me passer le sel.
J'étais stupéfaite.
On a donc scanné leurs cerveaux en leur demandant de regarder une photo de leur bien-aimé(e) puis une photo "neutre"
avec une pause entre les deux.
Ainsi nous pouvions trouver...regarder le même cerveau en état de forte activité
et en état de repos.
Et nous avons trouvé que de nombreuses régions du cerveau sont actives.
En fait, une des zones les plus actives
est la même que celle qui réagit lorsque vous ressentez l'effet d'une injection de cocaïne.
Et c'est exactement ce qui se passe.
J'ai commencé à réaliser que l'amour n'est pas une émotion.
J'avais toujours pensé qu'il s'agissait d'une série d'émotions
allant du très fort au très faible.
Mais c'est plutôt une dynamique. Ça part de l'esprit
de la volonté, de l'envie.
C'est la partie du cerveau
qui veut un morceau de chocolat,
qui veut gagner une promotion professionnelle.
Le moteur du cerveau. C'est un besoin.
Et je pense que c'est plus fort que la dynamique de l'envie sexuelle.
Si vous proposez à une personne de coucher avec vous et qu'elle répond "non merci"
vous n'allez certainement pas vous suicider ou sombrer dans la dépression.
Mais certainement, dans le monde, des gens tueront parce que leur amour est rejeté.
Les gens vivent pour l'amour. Ils tuent par amour. Ils meurent par amour.
Ils en font des chansons, des poèmes, des romans, des sculptures, des tableaux, des mythes, des légendes.
On a trouvé des preuves de ce puissant processus cérébral dans plus de 175 sociétés.
Je crois aujourd'hui que c'est le plus puissant processus cérébral au monde
générant à la fois une joie ou une détresse immense.
Et j'en suis arrivée à la conclusion qu'il s'agit de l'un des trois
processus cérébraux qui ont évolué à partir de l'accouplement et de la reproduction.
L'un d'entre eux est le besoin sexuel : l'envie d'une gratification sexuelle.
W.H. Auden a appelé cela "une intolérable démangeaison neurale"
et en effet, c'est de cela qu'il s'agit.
Ca vous titille un peu, comme quand vous avez faim.
Le second de ces processus cérébraux est l'amour :
cette exaltation, cette obsession propre à un amour naissant.
Et le troisième processus cérébral est l'attachement :
c'est une sensation de calme et de sécurité que l'on ressent pour un partenaire de long terme.
Et je pense que le besoin sexuel a évolué pour nous faire aller
à la recherche de partenaires.
Vous savez, vous pouvez le ressentir quand vous conduisez votre voiture.
Il peut même ne pas se porter sur une personne en particulier.
Je crois que l'amour a évolué pour nous permettre de canaliser notre envie d'accouplement
vers un seul individu à la fois,
en canalisant ainsi l'envie et les périodes d'accouplement.
Et je crois que l'attachement, le troisième processus cérébral
a évolué pour nous permettre de tolérer cet être humain, (Rires)
au moins assez longtemps pour élever un enfant ensemble.
Après ce préambule, je voudrais parler de ces deux tendances sociales.
L'une a 10.000 ans et l'autre... s'est imposée sans doute ces 25 dernières années...
et elles vont avoir un impact sur ces trois processus cérébraux :
le désir, l'amour et l'attachement profond pour un partenaire.
La première tendance est le travail des femmes, elles intègrent le monde du travail.
J'ai observé 150... 130 sociétés à travers les données démographiques des Nations Unies.
Et partout dans le monde, dans 129 sociétés sur 130, les femmes progressent sur le marché du travail
parfois très très lentement, mais elles avancent...
et elles comblent très lentement le fossé qui existe entre hommes et femmes
en termes de pouvoir économique, de santé et d'éducation.
C'est très lent.
Pour chaque tendance... sur cette planète, il y a une "contre-tendance".
Nous connaissons ça mais quand même... comme dit le proverbe arabe :
"Les chiens aboient et la caravane passe."
Et en effet, la caravane passe.
Les femmes avancent de nouveau sur le marché du travail.
Et je dis "de nouveau" parce que ce n'est pas la première fois.
Pendant des millions d'années, dans les prairies africaines,
les femmes se sont déplacées pour récolter des légumes.
Elles rentraient avec l'équivalent de 60 à 80% du repas du soir.
Un double revenu par famille était standard.
Et les femmes étaient considérées comme l'équivalent économique, social et sexuel de l'homme.
En résumé, nous avançons vers le passé.
Puis la pire invention pour la femme fut la charrue.
Quand la charrue a commencé à être utilisée dans l'agriculture, le rôle de l'homme s'est renforcé grandement.
Les femmes ont perdu leur travail de cueilleuses
mais avec la révolution industrielle et post-industrielle
elles ont réapparu sur le marché du travail.
En résumé, elles retrouvent la place qu'elles avaient voilà un million d'années,
il y a 10.000, 100.000 ans.
On retrouve l'une des traditions les plus remarquables de l'histoire de l'animal humain.
Et cela va avoir un impact.
Je donne souvent une conférence entière sur l'impact des femmes sur le monde économique.
Je vais juste aborder deux points et je passerai au sexe et à l'amour.
Il existe de nombreuses différences entre les sexes.
Celui qui pense que les hommes et les femmes sont semblables n'a jamais été parent d'un garçon et d'une fille.
Je ne sais pas pourquoi ils veulent penser que les hommes et les femmes soient semblables.
Nous avons beaucoup en commun, mais il y a beaucoup de choses
que nous n'avons pas en commun.
Nous sommes, selon Ted Hugues,
"Je crois que nous sommes faits pour être... nous sommes comme deux pieds. Nous avons besoin de l'autre pour avancer."
Mais nos cerveaux n'ont pas évolué de la même manière.
Et on trouve encore et toujours de nouvelles différences dans nos cerveaux.
Je vais juste aborder deux points puis je passerai au sexe et à l'amour.
Le premier point est la capacité verbale de la femme. Les femmes savent s'exprimer.
La capacité de la femme à trouver le mot juste rapidement, l'articulation basique
intervient au milieu du cycle menstruel lorsque le niveau d'oestrogène est au maximum.
Mais même au cours de la menstruation, elles sont meilleures que l'homme moyen.
Les femmes savent s'exprimer.
Elles parlent depuis un million d'années, les mots étaient les outils des femmes.
Elles ont tenu leur bébé face à elles,
l'ont cajolé, l'ont grondé, l'ont éduqué grâce aux mots.
Et elles acquièrent un pouvoir considérable.
Y compris dans des pays comme l'Inde ou le Japon
où les femmes progressent lentement dans le monde du travail,
elles entrent dans le journalisme.
Je pense que la télévision est comme un immense feu de camp.
On s'assied autour et elle forge nos esprits.
En général, lorsque je passe à la télévision, les producteurs qui m'appellent
pour négocier de ce dont on va parler, sont des femmes.
Soljenitsyne a dit:
"Avoir un grand écrivain, c'est avoir un autre gouvernement."
Aujourd'hui, 54% des écrivains américains sont des femmes.
C'est l'une des nombreuses caractéristiques que les femmes ont
et qu'elles proposent sur le marché du travail.
Elles ont des incroyables capacités de communication, de négociations.
Elles ont une immense imagination.
On connaît aujourd'hui le processus cérébral de l'imagination, de la planification à long terme.
Elles ont tendance à avoir une pensée en réseau.
parce que les éléments cérébraux féminins sont mieux connectés,
elles ont tendance à collecter plus de données lorsqu'elles réfléchissent,
à les inclure dans des actions plus complexes, à analyser davantage d'options et de solutions.
Elles collent au contexte, ont une approche holistique, ce que j'appelle une pensée en réseau.
Les hommes ont tendance... et ce sont des moyennes... à se débarrasser de ce qu'ils considèrent comme étranger à la question,
à se concentrer sur ce qu'ils font et à développer un type de réflexion étape par étape.
Ce sont deux types de réflexions efficaces.
Nous avons besoin des deux pour avancer.
En fait, il y a plus de génies masculins dans le monde.
Quand le... et il y a aussi beaucoup plus d'imbéciles masculins dans le monde. (Rires)
Quand le cerveau masculin fonctionne bien, il fonctionne extrêmement bien.
Et je... ce que je crois c'est que nous allons vers une société collaborative,
une société dans laquelle les talents des hommes et des femmes
sont de mieux en mieux compris, valorisés et utilisés.
Mais le fait que les femmes progressent sur le marché du travail a un énorme impact
sur la sexualité, l'amour et la vie de famille.
De plus, les femmes commencent à exprimer leur sexualité.
Je suis toujours frappée lorsque les gens me disent :
"Pourquoi l'adultère est-il si souvent masculin?"
et je réponds, "Pourquoi pensez-vous que l'adultère soit plus masculin que féminin?"
"Eh bien... l'adultère c'est les hommes!"
"Et vous pensez que ces hommes couchent avec qui?"
Et... logique mathématique! (Rires)
Bref.
Dans le monde occidental, les petites filles commencent...
les femmes ont des rapports sexuels plus précoces, ont plus de partenaires,
expriment moins de remords quant à leurs partenaires,
se marient plus tard, ont moins d'enfants, quittent un mauvais mariage pour trouver mieux.
On constate une expression grandissante de la sexualité féminine.
Et, encore une fois, on se dirige vers le même type d'expression sexuelle
que nous avons probablement connu dans les prairies africaines il y a un million d'années
parce que c'est le type d'expression sexuelle que l'on retrouve
dans les sociétés de chasse et les communautés aujourd'hui.
Nous revenons aussi à une forme ancienne d'égalité dans le mariage.
On dit que le XXIe siècle
sera le siècle du "mariage symétrique"
ou du "mariage pur" ou "mariage amical".
C'est le mariage entre égaux,
se dirigeant vers un concept en adéquation avec l'ancien esprit humain.
On constate aussi une montée de l'amour.
91% des femmes américaines et 86% des hommes américains
ne se marieraient pas avec quelqu'un même s'il avait toutes les qualités qu'ils recherchent chez un partenaire,
s'ils n'étaient pas amoureux de cette personne.
A travers l'étude de 37 sociétés, les êtres humains
veulent être amoureux de la personne qu'ils épousent.
Les mariages arrangés sont en effet en train de disparaître.
Je crois même que les mariages pourraient même devenir plus solides
grâce de la seconde grande tendance.
La première, ce sont les femmes qui progressent sur le marché de l'emploi,
la seconde c'est le vieillissement de la population.
On entend dire aujourd'hui aux Etats-Unis
que jusqu'à 85 ans, on est quelqu'un d'âge moyen,
parce que dans la classe la plus âgée de cette catégorie de gens, de 76 à 85 ans,
40% des gens vivent sans aucun problème.
On constate donc une réelle extension du concept de l'"âge moyen".
Et pour l'un de mes livres, j'ai étudié les divorces dans 58 sociétés.
Et la conclusion, c'est que plus vous vieillissez, moins vous avez de chances de divorcer.
Aux Etats-Unis, le taux de divorce aujourd'hui est stable
et il commence même à diminuer.
Il devrait encore baisser.
Et je dirais qu'avec le Viagra, les oestrogènes de synthèses, les prothèses de hanche
et les femmes incroyablement intéressantes...
Les femmes n'ont jamais été aussi intéressantes.
C'est la première fois dans l'histoire que les femmes sont aussi éduquées, intéressantes, qualifiées.
Et honnêtement, s'il est une époque dans l'histoire de l'humanité,
où nous avons l'occasion de réussir nos mariages, c'est aujourd'hui.
Bien sûr, il y a toujours des écueils.
Les trois processus cérébraux : le désir, l'amour et l'attachement
ne se combinent pas toujours parfaitement.
Ils peuvent très bien se combiner, cela dit en passant.
C'est pour cela que les relations sexuelles occasionnelles ne sont pas toujours si désinvoltes.
Au cours de l'orgasme, il y a un pic de dopamine.
La dopamine étant associée à l'amour,
vous avez une bonne chance de tomber amoureux d'une personne avec qui vous couchez occasionnellement.
Avec l'orgasme, vous avez une montée d'oxytocine et de vasopressine,
ces deux-là sont associés à l'attachement.
C'est pour cela qu'on ressent parfois un sentiment d'union cosmique avec quelqu'un,
après avoir fait l'amour.
Mais ces trois processus cérébraux : désir, amour et attachement,
ne sont pas toujours connectés entre eux.
Vous pouvez ressentir un profond attachement pour un partenaire de long terme
tout en ressentant un sentiment d'amour intense pour quelqu'un d'autre
et en ayant une attirance sexuelle pour d'autres personnes.
En résumé, nous sommes capables d'aimer plus d'une personne à la fois.
En fait, vous pouvez être allongé au lit la nuit
et passer de sentiments profonds d'attachement pour quelqu'un
à des sentiments d'amour intense pour quelqu'un d'autre,
un peu comme s'il y avait un comité qui se réunissait dans votre cerveau
pendant que vous essayez de décider ce que vous devez faire.
Et donc honnêtement, je ne pense pas que nous soyons un animal programmé pour être heureux,
mais plutôt destiné à nous reproduire.
Je crois que le bonheur que nous trouvons, nous le fabriquons.
Et je pense que nous pouvons tisser des bons liens entre nous.
Je conclurai avec deux points :
il y a un point qui m'inquiète,
une inquiétude et une magnifique histoire.
Cette inquiétude, ce sont les anti-dépresseurs.
Aux Etats-Unis, plus de 100 millions de prescriptions d'anti-dépresseurs sont délivrées chaque année.
Ces médicaments deviennent des génériques
et se répandent dans le monde entier.
Je connais une jeune fille qui prend des anti-dépresseurs à base de sérotonine
SSRI - des antidépresseurs augmentant la sérotonine - depuis qu'elle a 13 ans.
Elle en a aujourd'hui 23. Elle en prend depuis qu'elle a 13 ans
Je n'ai rien contre les personnes qui en prennent à court terme
lorsqu'ils traversent une situation pénible,
dans le cas de personnes qui veulent se suicider ou tuer quelqu'un,
c'est une très bonne chose à mon avis.
Mais aux Etats-Unis, de plus en plus de gens en prennent sur de longues périodes.
Et ces médicaments augmentent les niveaux de sérotonine
et en augmentant les niveaux de sérotonine, ils coupent le circuit de dopamine.
Tout le monde sait ça.
La dopamine est associée à l'amour.
Donc, non seulement le circuit de dopamine est coupé mais ils effacent le besoin sexuel.
Et en tuant le besoin sexuel, vous tuez l'orgasme.
Et en tuant l'orgasme, vous tuez le flux d'hormones associé à l'attachement.
Ces éléments sont connectés dans le cerveau.
Et lorsque vous intervenez sur un processus cérébral,
vous touchez à un autre processus.
Je dis simplement qu'un monde sans amour est un endroit mortel.
Et... (Applaudissements)... Merci.
Je voudrais terminer par une histoire et puis un commentaire.
J'étudie l'amour, le sexe et l'attachement depuis 30 ans.
J'ai une soeur jumelle et je m'intéresse à nos points communs.
Pourquoi sommes-nous identiques, pourquoi les Irakiens, les Japonais
les Aborigènes d'Australie et les peuples du fleuve Amazone sont-ils tous semblables?
Il y a un an, un site de rencontres, Match.com m'a contactée
et m'a demandée de dessiner un nouveau site de recontre pour eux.
Je leur ai dit: "Je ne connais rien en matière de personnalité,
vous êtes sûrs de vous adresser à la bonne personne?"
"Oui." ont-ils dit.
Cela m'a forcée à me demander pourquoi on tombe amoureux d'une personne plutôt que d'une autre.
C'est le projet sur lequel je travaille, ce sera le sujet de mon prochain livre.
Il y a tout un tas de raisons qui font que vous tombez amoureux d'une personne plutôt que d'une autre.
Le timing est important, la proximité est importante.
Le mystère est important. Vous tombez amoureux de quelqu'un qui porte un certain mystère
en partie parce que le mystère accentue le taux de dopamine dans le cerveau,
et sans doute vous fait franchir le seuil du sentiment amoureux.
Vous tombez amoureux de quelqu'un qui correspond à ce que j'appelle "votre carte amoureuse"
une liste inconsciente de points que vous construisez de l'enfance à l'âge adulte.
Et je pense aussi que ce que vous devenez...
que vous fréquentez des gens qui ont, d'une certaine manière, des processus cérébraux complémentaires.
Et c'est sur cela que je travaille maintenant.
Mais je voudrais vous raconter une histoire, en guise d'exemple.
Je viens de parler de l'aspect biologique de l'amour,
je voudrais aussi vous montrer un peu de la culture de l'amour,
de la magie de l'amour.
C'est une anecdote que m'a raconté quelqu'un qui venait de l'entendre de...
probablement une histoire vraie.
C'était un jeune diplômé à... Je suis à Rutgers et mes deux collègues...
à Art Aaron et SUNY Stonybrook.
C'est l'endroit où nous mettons les gens dans le scanner IRM.
Et cet étudiant était follement amoureux d'une autre étudiante
mais elle ne l'aimait pas.
Et ils participaient à une conférence à Beijing.
Et il savait de notre étude que si vous faites quelque chose de nouveau avec quelqu'un
vous pouvez provoquer une montée de dopamine dans son cerveau
et peut-être déclencher un sentiment amoureux. (Rires)
Alors il a décidé de faire appel à la science
et il a invité la jeune fille à faire un tour de pousse-pousse avec lui.
Je n'ai jamais essayé mais apparemment
vous zigzaguez entre les bus, les camions
tout va très vite, il y a du bruit, c'est excitant.
Et il a pensé que cela provoquerait une montée de dopamine
et qu'elle tomberait amoureuse de lui.
Les voilà donc partis : elle pousse des cris, se serre contre lui,
ils rient et passent un moment merveilleux.
Une heure plus tard, ils descendent du pousse-pousse,
elle lève les bras en l'air et dit: "C'était pas génial?"
puis, "le chauffeur du pousse-pousse était super beau, non?"
(Rires) (Applaudissements)
La magie de l'amour!
Je finirais en disant qu'il y a un million d'années, nous avons développé trois besoins fondamentaux :
le besoin sexuel, l'amour et l'attachement pour un partenaire à long terme.
Ces circuits marquent profondément l'esprit humain.
Ils survivront aussi longtemps que notre espèce survivra
dans ce que Shakespeare appelle "cette enveloppe mortelle."
Merci. (Applaudissements)